I'm going to get to the next name which
is my next sort of direction to look for
is is there some kind of symmetry here
is there some symmetry that I can take
advantage of and the reason why I think
of symmetry is not just because I know
symmetry is a thing but look at these
guys you see these highly symmetrical
ray and all of these graphs that I've
been looking at so far have had various
kinds of symmetries right or the circle
has an infinite number of axes of
surgery gives has to the primer has one
right so you might be at all am I losing
my axis of symmetry but the algebra kind
of suggests that there would be some pro
symmetry so the first thing I've done is
intercepts the second thing I'm going to
do is search for some symmetry so this
is like this is sorry
one incense number 2 i'm looking for
some surgery
I don't even symmetry are the normal
kinds of surgery they are most familiar
how I go about determining whether and
by the way i can't say function can I
this is not a function it's pretty easy
to seize your supplements and values you
not get just one output for every input
for this relation how do I go about
finding orange
yeah i want to i need a definition for
like this is this is what would give me
even symmetry rangel and this is what
we're good whoops to minimalism odd
symmetry right so if i want this wine it
is everything as a function of X does
that make sense what things are the
function X this is not written as a
function of X particles another function
okay but it's not written in terms of X
at all air all the excellent ones just
kind of jumbled together so let's
rearrange this thing okay let's go make
why the subject right I'm going to get X
so minus y squared on 12 and I'll kick
over that expert on for over this way
how does that okay
now to me why the subject I need to get
rid of these two constants here the
minus 1 and the 12 with a minus network
so we multiply both sides by negative
[ __ ] top okay that'll make y square
this object so that's going to give me
from negative 12 plus 3x squared are you
happy with that left 13 one more step
I'll kind of you two things at once I'll
take the square root of both sides but
I'm going to get a plus a length is
there are two solutions up while I'm at
it I might as well check the order of
this sort looks a little more friendly
that's what I've got okay now pause for
a moment even offer it in y equals this
is an expression over here that changes
right it's in terms of X so therefore
now I have it in this kind of form do I
observe any kind of symmetry yeah bet I
do right look at this okay if I put in
an x value I'm going to dad say put in x
equals 1 right it gets squared so if you
put in negative 1 you're going to get
the same value back I lose that sign
right so therefore if I put in x equals
1 I would get well exercised about it
because I'm I'm I'm not you don't
evaluate back
let's try x equals an arm at x equals 2
for the x equals 4 will give me a nice
number right I'll use this in a second
if etic was four then y is going to
equal to also minus the square root of
three times that's kind of heavy right
so this is 36 so I'm getting this right
but if I try x equals negative 4 I don't
even need to go to the effort do I write
because as soon as you put it in here
it's going to behave exactly the way for
did because it gets squared out does
that make sense so this is the chlorides
look at before I think there might be
symmetry and sure enough so when x
equals negative 4 why are you not equal
plus or minus 6 now I'm noticing a
couple of interesting things right the
first thing is I have identified even
symmetry that's good so if I have one
half over here I'm going to get the same
part over here okay that's good but just
like the values that I tested do you
notice even symmetry which is a
horizontal thing right it means I can
reflect horizontally even symmetry isn't
the only thing that has emerged do you
notice this right but it's plus or minus
6 awesome amazing if I put other values
in here I'm what is going to get plus or
minus cosmos whatever right so that
means there is not just horizontal
symmetry there is also a vertical
symmetry okay now we don't have a fancy
names that like even a nite solution but
i'm just going to note that
I have symmetry which I really should
there's reflective symmetry across the
x-axis that's vertical and across the
y-axis now i'm not going to bother going
to the effort of three allowed to break
away but I could have noticed that
without just subbing in that because you
see this process we went through to get
y in terms of X I could have done it in
reverse I could have got X in terms of Y
and I would have observed exactly the
same thing I would have had an y squared
term i made the square root it's going
to have the same kind of doesn't matter
what side you put in you get the same
thing out alright so I've got some
symmetry what else might be useful to me
it
okay i will get to the extremities but
that's a bit it's a bit harder takes a
bit more work before I get a bit I
should notice when you have a look at
here right I just observe symmetry so
see how I've got a vodka CR well if the
things symmetrical I guess that means
it'll have a focus over there too but
and we already have encountered this
kind of thing your lips right now this
was symmetrical this shame is going to
be symmetrical so it's going to have two
foci and I guess that means it's also
going to have to register
soulful this D and D dash and SMS dash
okay now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to have a look and now which would
be the most hopeful line oh yeah okay
let me go what I'm trying to do is
constantly push on algebra and see what
kind of geometric insights it can give
me right now as soon as I see that I'm
just write it in visitors y squared we
use 3 x squared minus love remembering
that even though we know that complex
numbers I'm only dealing on in the
Cartesian plane so it's real and real
right that means certain things are true
about Y square which are also true or 3x
square miles talk because it same thing
right if I'm only in the real numbers
that means i know the smallest Y squared
can possibly be the smallest it can be
as wise a real number is 0 do you agree
with that the only way to get y squared
two negatives to pub some complex
numbers in it and I'm planning a bit off
so being a y squared must be positive
that means that 3x squared minus 12 must
be positive I'm okay [ __ ] square to
get zero that's all right what is going
to tell me are we going to get out of
this quiescent fight a little bit or
which I'm going to do guess I'll um I'll
i actually am going to avoid taking
things either side you'll see why I'm
going tonight I think dividing would be
simple that's good all right here and
then now I that's a difference of
squares so I'm going to factorize that
now what does this represent this is a
parabola parabola it's got written
negative two and two and I want to know
where is it positive can you tell me
where it's on the outsides ism this is a
concave up parabola okay so therefore
i'm getting less than negative 2 or it's
greater than 2 what does this represent
what is this we have available it's time
this is the domain right remember I said
what y square has to be positive this is
the only place it exists and this is
what follows if I draw my thing for you
so now I know about the domain ok so
remember about the intercepts negative 2
and 2 I can't go inside here I have to
say outside does that make sense that's
what this domain time